8% des français qui sont célibataires
vous en faites partie non non comme chez
vous ce nom et le nom de comme quand ta
mère elle te demande de schirrhein
amoureux n'ont quà n'est pas célibataire
celui-ci vous voyez on peut pas tout
avoir
il ya des priorités on peut pas voir un
gars qui est plus célibataire la musique
truc les mecs on a des priori pour toi
aicha bah ça vous change la vision des
choses pas le petit doigt nous d après
toi maxime alors oui ça me semble
épanouie oui oui ça va très bien quoique
amoureux je trade un mode ça fait
quelques très bons mois n'est pas bien
d'officialiser les choses il ya une
question tweet depouilly qui disait
pourquoi tu exposes pas ta vie privée
tout simplement parce que pour vivre
heureux il faut vivre caché et ce que
j'ai beaucoup donné
j'avais alors d'amour et plus comme un
partenaire à la décline depuis plus d'un
an peut-être nourrison non c'est toi à
travers lequel il faut savoir pour sait
jamais si c'est bon si c'est pas bon
alors ils ont classé fait le sieur a
basculé ce week-end ses créations mais
la whey toi tu sais fait ce week end
ça y est je regardais la télévision
chercher mon top suite et la whey d'une
révélation matin la révélation oui quoi
c'est bon tu as quelqu'un oui ça je suis
bien et prénoms n'ont heureusement oui
il est prêt on ne peut pas donner le
prix d'opa pour l'instant il faut pas
une fois j'ai donné le prénom et ce week
end
mais c'est vers ce week-end à pécho ça y
est tu trouves ça ça veut dire que ça
s'est fait chahuter la ville couvert lui
et que je suis pas le premier soir
d'habitude cyril vous savez tout ouais
tout des gens de l'est qui voilà vous
avez forcément une piste ordures
nutrition vous dis la vérité jaulin non
voilà c'est passé cette question au
hasard machines
ça fait un an que je suis sur la sphère
gainey c'est vrai en plus ça oui c'est
vrai et ça fait un an que je sais rien
j'attendais juste
le déclic un un sujet lourd des amoureux
à dessein et gagnent ici vous accueille
aujourd'hui si vous êtes là toute la
semaine
ça n'est pas anodin aux as mais j'ai des
traces adn
kenny fait gaffe shaker mais c'est vrai
mais ça me fait très plaisir
et j'aime beaucoup la personne dont je
suis très content vous connaissez la
personne car elle bien sûr on la connaît
nous non toutes personnes venues qui à
contacter de près ou de loin avec un
script d'un chroniqueur je le sais à
part lui parce qu'il ya trop de monde
[Applaudissements]